hey this is really funny
sean hannity last night on his fox news
propaganda program
scrolled a list of trump's crimes and
misdeeds on the screen
thinking that it's a great defense of
trump thinking it's some kind of a
exculpation of trump's misdeeds
and it makes trump look guiltier than
ever you you just have to see this video
sean hannity is a big trump propagandist
and even though as january sixth riots
were unfolding we know now hannity was
texting and saying he's got this we've
got to stop this he's got to go out and
put a stop to this this is really really
bad he has become a default apologist
for everything that donald trump has
done and one of the stories that sean
hannity loves to tell is that all these
investigations of trump were very much
unfair and he quite literally scrolls
the investigations on the screen last
night
and it actually reminded me that trump
has been involved in way more wrongdoing
than i even had present in my mind
because there's been so much of it take
a look at this this is just unbelievable
there's witch hunt the emoluments clause
investigation from the house oversight
committee a house ways and means
investigation into trump's taxes another
house investigation into trump's hotel
lease another house investigation into
foreign gift disclosures a d.c probe
into trump's inauguration fundraising
another similar investigation from the
southern district of new york and the
eastern district of new york and from
new jersey's attorney general one
impeachment investigation into a regular
phone call with ukraine a second
impeachment investigation into by the
way just one little detail i hate to
interrupt this i like how hannity calls
it a regular phone call with ukraine
trump calls it a perfect phone call
that would have been a bit too much even
for hannity that would have made hannity
blush so hannity goes with a regular
phone call um while watching this i
found myself thinking like as as the
scroll went up and down the screen as
you can see here i find once i think oh
oh yeah oh that's right that other oh i
completely forgot about this one well
that on that one he's obviously guilty
on that one hannity thinks this is some
kind of defense of trump
and
what is basically being said when
hannity scrolls this indignantly is
why can't they just let him do whatever
the hell he wants to do
whether it's criminal whether it's moral
whether it's ethical let him do it in
peace anything short of that is a
complete and total witch hunt and it's
quite frankly convenient for hannity to
put all of this stuff in one place for
us this is not the defense of trump that
i think sean hannity wanted it to be and
it's a really useful
uh clearinghouse for us to remember all
of the incredible things that he has
done for frame of reference
one of these things
if it were obama
would have been an incredible scandal on
fox news that they would not have let
obama live down obama
exactly uh and of course there's dozens
and dozens of these if you want to if
you're just listening today
and you want to see this incredible
scroll of trump's misdeeds from fox
we'll have the clip up on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
i've seen several people in my life try
to quit smoking or vaping and quitting
has so many benefits but it does require
a strategy and our sponsor fume is a
one-of-a-kind inhaler that can help you
quit smoking as a replacement for the
hand-to-mouth habit of smoking there is
no smoke there is no vapor and there's
no nicotine fume is just a small inhaler
hand crafted from wood it uses cores
infused with fresh aromatic plant oils
for you to taste and enjoy
instead of a nasty cigarette or a vape
you can use fume while flying which is a
big plus
because there's no smoke no vapor no
nicotine fume has flavors like
peppermint and conker with a powerful
minty sensation to simulate the menthol
cigarettes they have other flavors like
cozy chai i love chai myself and lemon
berry bliss for a sweeter experience
fume has helped thousands of people quit
people who have tried everything else
read the reviews we talked to the fume
team they're very proud of the lives
that they've impacted throw out the
cigarettes get rid of the vapes head
over to breathe fume dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman to get 10
percent off your entire order the link
is down below